well
hello how are you andrés gonzález greets you
with his pre informative for today tuesday the
first of june from midnight
clark county is back to 100%
capacity with them they eliminated all the
restrictions established by the
pandemic and this is how the
freemont streep of the  downtown with a
live music show after more than a year
many tourists were ready to
celebrate although some prefer that
some measures be maintained for a
while businesses have control
over asking yes or no to use the
mask and maintain distance
social inside its premises
and with all these changes it returns to the
payment for parking for the
cosmopolitan and other resorts of the script
of las vegas local people
can still park free for the
first 3 hours inside the
properties belonging to the
souls swarm, discounts are also offered  for
military and veterans there are also
for members of the stars or
ran program  higher gos visit our page
for more details
the moratorium on evictions in nevada has
expired and there will be no extension if you
still need assistance to pay
your rent the cdc moratorium is in
effect until july 30 visit
youzhny dotcom diagonal in spanish
to find out how to receive help after
receiving an eviction order
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we will have a hot week with
temperatures reaching triple digits
starting tomorrow you are
reminded to keep pets inside the
home and avoid being in the sun for hours  of
extreme heat have a good day I
am andrés gonzález and this was about the
news now in Spanish
[Music]